one of the great challenges we may have
in afghanistan hereafter will be the
threat from terrorism and the answer is
that we will work with our allies and
particularly the americans to see how we
can get after that threat um from
outside afghanistan back into
afghanistan if it's necessary
and obviously that is going to be a
taliban-led regime can you imagine that
um the uk and its allies might be
working with the taliban to go after the
islamic state threat
um i mean
it's of course it's not inconceivable
but of course we um we're pretty clear
about who we work with uh they need to
accord to certain principles uh and
lawful behavior um and um if the taliban
are able to demonstrate that they can
behave in the way that a normal
government would behave in relation to
the terrorist threat then we may well
discover that we operate together but i
think we've got to wait and see is the
answer as to how they're going to behave
in relation to this and certainly some
of the stories we get about the way that
they're treating um their enemies uh
would mean it would be quite difficult
for us to work with them at the moment i
would suspect withdrawal and therefore
with it evacuation is i think generally
regarded as the hardest phase of any of
the phases of war for us as military
people and the reason it's so difficult
is you don't really have the initiative
and of course there has to be a ever
diminishing rear guard that protects
your back as your as you're evacuating
yourselves and of course there comes a
point when it really is the last
aeroplane out
um and there are all sorts of things
that could go wrong um i mean obviously
public disorder is a real challenge and
we saw that two weekends ago when a lot
of very desperate afghans tragically
made their way onto the runway um and
then of course there is the threat of
terrorism um and um that threat is not
going to go away and you are at your
very most vulnerable at the point at
which your last airplane is waiting to
lift
so i think um i think we should be
holding our breath and um thinking
really hard of you know that last
airplane or several last airplane loads
and thinking about what a challenge it's
going to be for those very brave people
trying to
affect their departure in a safe and
orderlier fashion as they can
foreign affairs editor debra haynes
joins us now deborah interesting to hear
that about that last flight with
civilians on board just how dangerous is
that going to be
well he's he's describing about how
they are obviously in a very dangerous
situation anyway in kabul airport the
security provided by the taliban and
this very real threat of a terrorist
attack as demonstrated
on thursday with that horrendous suicide
bombing and so the problem that the um
the british and the americans have is
that as they also have to leave they're
going to have their own ability to
secure themselves diminishing and while
the last british evacuation flight is
happening today the americans are still
carrying on with their evacuation
efforts and they have a much bigger
presence and they have provided the
majority of the security and so when
british troops are expected to leave
before the americans and i think general
carter's thoughts are really with the
american forces who will be on that
final flight the very last flight that
leaves kabul airport and he's saying
about how at that moment that's the
moment of maximum risk every flight that
takes off is phil is it has risk with it
he said to me in that interview as well
that
including the threat from a suicide
bombing there's also a very real threat
of an attack against one of these
aircrafts you could you know fire
gunfire at it or mortar fire
and so each plane that takes off has
that risk and as the forces draw down as
well their ability to counter the risk
also reduces so with every flight that
goes off and with fewer troops on the
ground the greater the danger and and
that's very much what he's alive to and
that's why he uses those words about
holding our breath but you also need to
hold your breath for all of those that
haven't made these flights while it's
it's you know the uk effort almost 15
000 people evacuated to safety there are
many thousands more still in danger
including interpreters who used to work
for the british forces and they are
incredibly scared today